did i miss anything
there's like a different vibe in here
amy schumer shocked and confused like
the rest of us shortly after will smith
slapped chris rock during the oscars
now the 40 year old comedian who emceed
the big night is weighing in admitting
she is still triggered and traumatized
by the whole thing just a little
refresher guys i'm a huge star look at
me i'm at the oscars you are can you
believe it amy co-hosted the 2022
academy awards alongside regina hall and
wanda sykes and the ladies brought the
funny getting to do this with regina and
wanda they are such heroes of mine they
are comedy royalty we've been having so
much fun i've enjoyed every second of
getting ready with these ladies but it
was this joke made by chris rock that
had everyone talking jaina i love you
g.i jane 2 can't wait to see it all
right
okay so it wasn't the joke that had
everyone talking it was jada pinkett
smith's husband will smith's reaction to
the joke that had everyone talking
oh wow
wow
will smith just smacked out of me
well on tuesday amy weighed in on
instagram saying that her friend chris
handled it like a pro she calls the
whole thing so disturbing and writes
that she's still in shock and stunned
and sad she even specifically calls out
the pain she saw in will
waiting for this sickening feeling to go
away from what we all witnessed
oh wow
will smith just smacked out of me
but that wasn't the only oscar
controversy amy addressed oh gosh i mean
i did my darndest i'll just say that
during the show the trainwreck star did
a bit with jessie plemmons where she
explained to the audience at home what a
seat filler is
a seat filler btw is exactly what it
sounds like if a celeb gets up out of
their seat a seat filler steps in so
that the audience always looks full on
camera anyway to give the viewers an
example amy jokingly called oscar
nominee kirsten dunst a seat filler and
asked her to get up okay here's a seat
filler can we get you up honey jesse and
his lady love looked super confused
and while many realized that it was
clearly a joke others weren't so sure
and came to kirsten's defense on social
media
you know that was my wife him
you're married to that seat filler
so on monday amy revealed that the
couple was actually in on it and we can
all feel free to lol quote hey i
appreciate the love for kirsten dunst i
love her too that was a choreographed
bit she was in on wouldn't disrespect
that queen like that
of course both jessie and kirsten were
nominated for their roles in the power
of the dog however neither of them took
home oscar gold but it wasn't a total
loss because the mom and dad of two made
a date night out of it i mean we don't
have kids right now so i as late as i
can stay up i will stay up
you